j'aimerais beaucoup vous présenter
quelqu'un
il vient dans le goulet mme
lucien de rubempré
pour vous servir
[Musique]
pour lui la poésie est une chose sacrée
sorte de religion intime qu'il arrive de
partir ans un baril
ces personnes travaillent monsieur je
respecte énormément le métier d'analyste
et tu crois que c'est quoi mon métier
vous éclairer les gens sur bar
le monde
mon métier c'est de réussir les
actionnaires du journal
l'autre ligne éditoriale sera sans le
journal tirera pour vrai tout ce qui est
probable
[Musique]
je sais qu'il vaut mieux que cela on
croyait
tous ces magouilles du bruit du vent il
nous faut apprendre à jouer avec tout ça
[Musique]
tout est pourri partout tu trouves pas
il faut se battre pour faire des pas de
choses
[Musique]
la mauvaise foi
la fosse de moeurs et de l'annonce
publicitaires
je te baptise journalistes
[Musique]
nous à travailler dessus bien
sur la barre
il faut taper là où ça fait mal
trop tard pour avoir peur
[Musique]